I said if my kid ever told me you wanted
the atomic out go in the other room and
get a gun and I'd walk back in the
living room and just look him in the
eyes go be funny and end it yeah
sellout that kid would be on top
of comedy joining us he'll be headlining
go bananas in Cincinnati tomorrow
through Saturday and go bananas comedy
calm Sean Patton
Hey welcome back to the show wait am i
yeah I think I was last time I was here
you were both going to Cincinnati
yeah and I was shocked by how and I
don't mean to put your business out
there how nervous of a flier you are
yeah I was surprised surprised so
surprised
I'm nervous flier but I hide it well
yeah and I hide it pretty well unless to
get that might have been a particularly
rocky ride or so so I think it's rocky
at all you you you get tense I feel like
if I look I mean III holding him pretty
good but it starts going like pretty
hate and also depending on my mood
sometimes I'm ready to die on the land
put me in the sky today today
it's gonna happen you're bring it on air
bitch that was a that was a good week
then because you seemed very nervous I
was not into dying because I don't like
that guy though who like in those
moments will say like well you know
there's I mean you're safer up here than
you are stop being negative to make this
a positive no but you you know one of
them with a bunch of other random people
on it we're driven into a
building yeah I mean like happen
yeah sometimes that plane does
go down and then you can't find that guy
to be like hey hey isn't it funny what
you put on it though like the city also
you're like the one that's gonna go
forget even terrorism yeah yeah let's
just talk like the thing like the story
the big national story it's like it's
never gonna be going from like
Greensboro South Carolina it is no to
like no but in your mind it's not going
to be but exactly what it is it's
Malaysian flight whatever yeah just a
random flight the yeah that guy that guy
who's like who's not afraid to file and
talks about I like I hope
he that person is in a plane crash and
everyone survives except him
yeah it's not an Alanis Morisette lyric
no that isn't it ironic whatever
non-ironic ironic the only ironic part
of that song is he is its existence yeah
that's what that's the whole thing it
was a whole work actually yeah you Becca
release thank you from like a straight
up like grammatical sense it is a
perfect lesson in irony yeah like she
was attempting to be ironic and do you
think she was that obtuse with the a day
of the song I think that's probably how
dumb a lot of the record execs are too
they don't know it already actually
they're like this is great this is smart
I love it she's an angel people gonna
learn people are learning people are
learning about irony and we're learning
about you know platinum albums yeah
making them jagged little pill I was
having a - it goes here's a spoon he
goes isn't it ironic I need a knife yeah
I just met the girl of my dreams I just
met the guy my dreams
nice beautiful wife you gay yeah yes
don't you think I'm already late yeah my
planes crashed I go well isn't that nice
yeah I've been afraid to do this yeah we
were talking before the break before you
came in about horn no that was yesterday
I do also hate when you find a no smile
on your cigarette break dude
I was a lot of smoke anywhere else I win
the lotto and died the next day
am I right or am I wrong before the
break we were talking about people men
with dual families with like two
families wait because we didn't have we
were talking about having a shitty
father
you mean like Gambino Bonanno like you
belong to both no not crying families
actually father like me and Danny
there's a Mel over here I think you've
seen the recipient of the second
generation of all now you see what my
work is done there but we're talking
about like you know if you have a shitty
dad like you want siblings no I'm saying
you want to be a better if you were to
have a kid right you know Lewis was an
example of that like Lewis J Gomez great
father really tough you know how to dad
that got murdered
was not his life then he's a great dad
right so we were saying how was at
least a living day he's a living at his
it alive my thought was I think what
would me up psychologically more
than having a dead dad would be having a
dad that's alive with another family and
hiding it from you like living with you
at your house and with your mom and then
goes and has another family life there's
a character on billions dollar bill that
has that my dad didn't do that my dad
like my guruji your dad went out and was
just like a single it was an indoor
come outside and he did not come home Oh
dance Network son I'm not to work at now
yes dad he wore sunglasses at night for
sure my dad definitely had I remember
that's alive do you know no my dad died
when I was 14 oh yeah he went out
that kill the show yeah that turn into
cirrhosis really yeah eventually became
AIDS from his body ashes got it oh he
got the Hep C from dirty tattoo needle
where he's getting his other family it's
actually mark Wiese yeah and that is
your brother
and he is actually a d1 prospect on some
level that would be ironic dying from
that tattoo yeah I know he isn't it
ironic
he'd got it I think banging some piece
of Lake trash which lake lake
lake lake Clear Lake in Northern
California onic Lee titled Clear Lake
here's where he got some murky do not
only that but he a wide mouth
bass yeah my dad was in the fish
he was like Troy McClure my dad was at
the Troy McClure section gosh vans dad
used to go okie noodling with his dick
yeah he goes hey do you want to go we
get catfish hang on hang on hang on arms
up
because you want to go to the fish
market just look around I like the idea
of your dad banging a rainbow trout to a
fish album yeah the whole solo oh you
have you ever had tantric fish sex you
as long as they jam rainbow trout I
ain't gay ain't no gay fish - it's crazy
ality that my dad got Hep C from this
lady and it killed him but it also
killed his sister cuz he she was a nurse
my aunt she came to take care of him and
he threw a blood and I got in her eye
and she yeah last thing about my grandma
that's what that's like when things dad
was dating hepatitis Cheryl Cheryl like
a bad scene in oz what are you for yeah
what are you in for a lot of bloody
stuff a lot of stuff a lot of well I
bleed a lot so I leave a lot of evidence
behind
now some finger paint with my blood my
what's fun this is anyway I usually kill
myself and see my own semen this is or
whatever this is up but it made
me laugh my I was playing I always play
cards with my grandma when I see her we
play and there's no TV in that room but
college football's always on because
it's like Thanksgiving so I keep the TV
on to listen to what college football
games going on and my grandma and I are
playing cards and it's like I cured my
hepatitis C and 14 days it's just like
hey I'm trying to distract her Oh over
here both of her kids got taken out by
this disease that this commercials just
talking about or it's like and I
cured it scot-free and my grandma I was
like yeah gin every time I hear it gives
me warm fuzzies all over again you are a
fantastic grandson ah thanks man
you really only wait what do you mean
that you every year at least once yeah I
mean I think it's correct - grandma yeah
I go he goes out there and spends like a
weekend yeah but I'm all she has
yeah literally no and services north to
San Francisco but he really knows what
he's just saying he's like sitting there
playing gin rummy yeah yeah you say Lake
County Lake County away from that get
away from the lake man no my grandma
lives on the lake move her out of there
all of our old friends are there and
they're all but she's still
hepatitis Carl yeah I go hep hep Emmett
you give an old way
hepatitis Emmett comes around other
other appetite is's of the other 25
letters in the office a and B hey you
get from eating or like food you
can get it from me as well so you can
get the feeding but be co-pays I keep a
people yeah sees that sees the debt she
gets you but now they can cure it my dad
got it 97 out of it 97 my aunt died of
it in Oh seven and she like extended her
life
choose boozing ain't care could rip it
what your dad would you would you if you
were time could you would you travel
back in time with the Karen secured dad
would you let him go yeah that's a good
question yet your father at all you out
cure it yeah just to talk yes or to
fight him fight boy named Sue Gary I'm
gonna cure you and I don't want to kick
this that's a great name is
hepatitis
yeah I would go back and say oh dal-su
with a seal I can definitely definitely
save my aunt yeah Dominick's ooh yeah if
I had to go pick like if you made me
choose aunt my aunt or my dad that'd be
tougher choice version of this song is
the way laptop I wasn't traveled back in
time with the cure for John this family
found my dad drinking at a bar it was
the bowling alley work that I walked in
I said I said hey Dad I missed you he
said it's five o'clock somewhere and he
said I'm at Margaritaville oh what's
your name hey it's the big-headed kid I
had with the mean bitch I bet you look
at that quarter length socks some slides
but get my dad didn't wear socks at all
no my dad wore boat shoes in
corduroys shorts with no underwear of
those shoes my dad dressed for cirrhosis
[Laughter]
in sweats for an AIDS Day a lot of
jackets I'm dressing for scurvy get some
lime yeah yeah my dad didn't wear socks
and no longer I believe it I thought it
were his feet ripe now he had like tough
Islander feet yes right I don't smell
anymore so you don't sweat he burned off
all the he's burned all the drinking
enough alcohol to sterilize anything on
his body I'm surprised
share the Hep C ii attention is
alcohol its bloodstream she catches on
fire pepsi you say i'm knock that out by
night yeah sometimes I get it when I'm
bored
yeah I was watching to do I feel like
Wolverine you know I got there give
myself lockjaw just for fun what dad's
name Dean Gary that's why we're sons of
Gary his dad he is a shitty dad named
Gary - that's why we're so close
my dad's name's Tim he's pretty cool
yeah Tim doesn't like a good dad name
kids are coming over back I loved
him where are you guys doing moon tower
that year that they gave everyone
flashlights yeah yeah yeah I wasn't
there that I was there that year you
were and everybody pretended like they
didn't go immediately to their room and
use it I was I was embarrassed that I
didn't finish in it I think I've owned -
I think I've owned - I've never utilized
either I felt like a serial killer
because like what is this is this an
organ is this a dead person tor it's
weird which which mount did you
use what do you mean because if they had
the vaginal opening the hole opening and
then just the slit I didn't know that i
thought i just opened the top like a
thermos and they were there you must
have not got the deluxe deluxe dandy
that's what you and your headliner food
are and then every was also at the
Radisson do they're all the Radisson
purple grass okay I know it's a good
thing a Rambo knife yeah oh my god
there's a compass on the bottom there's
a whole sewing kit every tweezers
there's one single match a blue tip
though you can light it on any strike
anywhere it's actually they recommend
you open a bottle of wine with it while
using it don't you understand this dildo
is the best everyone just left them in
the hotel rooms second things that
make a billy goat
because Colonel Trautman I gave a good
job but you bored
well of course you know that night that
Stallone you just did yeah this Rambo
baby is particularly my Rambo yeah
it's a Stallone in the key of Rambo key
of can't even good job parking I thought
I could I still have never seen the
first Rambo you've never seen first boy
I know I've always just I've only seen
the one where he's in the jungle no we
had one of the most fun that's best one
is Rambo where's blood easily the best
one we don't blow it yet I know I said
we just do a fun thing on yeah on the
lost it's Joe DeRosa has a very
interesting take on first blood that's a
little preview for the lost at sea tapes
the recorder on the Impractical Jokers
cruise oh you guys both there yeah
just living living do you want to talk
about it I mean we have a bunch of
episodes that we recorded on the boat
fun hang though DeRosa was there for
days and he didn't jump off one we
thought he might have Saturday night I
thought last night he was gonna go for
it who's sad he was like sad drunk he's
like it was wrong he thought everyone
was mad at up at different times and
then you'd be like galloping it's that
big of a deal you go what did i do man
why me why always me I'm like it's final
things any of that big of a deal he goes
what I do man you always come back like
15 minutes later and go he goes Polly
they said they were joke and they
weren't mad at me yeah and then every
time you talked to Nader I it was like
during play craps go get ice cream yeah
I heard
craps an ice cream dude I heard this
story about him at Edinburgh a few years
ago they know about a DeRosa that his
roommates kept putting dead bees in his
room just to hear him freak out whose
room is it Ari was one of them okay how
are you told me this story and then I
forgot it but two Brits I think but they
had are just some scholars okay
yes soft-bodied man loses his here
hearing the did be nice be they can't
handle a wasp it
[Music]
oh you want to see a month fly through
the roof or she's gonna be himself hey
you should leave a comment below one of
us might be in a depression spiral and
read it yeah push us all the way down
yeah yeah yeah I can get pretty dark
it's weird so look forward to reading it